voilà
ben
tu en voilà
on est repartis ce que je vous avais pas
dit tout à l'heure sur les biocarburants
c'est que vous avez souple est vous avez
un autre une autre
vous avez un autre impact qui peut avoir
lieu qui n'a pas lieu dans le pays dans
lesquels les surfaces agricoles sont
déjà installés et donc vous avez pas
besoin d'en créer une nouvelle pour
faire des dieux que faire pour faire la
matière végétale qui va vous servir à
faire des biocarburants mais par contre
ça peut être le cas dans certains pays
tropicaux dans lesquels pour installer
les cultures qui vont vous servir à
faire des biocarburants vous commencez
par couper de la fois c'est le fameux de
20 sur les palmiers à huile en indonésie
c'est le fameux débat sur la canne à
sucre au brésil alors c'est très
difficile de savoir j'ai malheureusement
pas prévu pour là dessus j'aurais pu
c'est très difficile de savoir ce qu'il
en est exactement ce qui concerne la
déforestation avoir des statistiques
fiables en matière de déforestation est
proche du casse tête
mais il n'en reste pas moins que quand
vous remplacer un écosystème de type
agricole dans lequel vous avez de
londres je pars donc à vous remplacer un
écosystème de type naturel s'il vous
plaît on vous remplacer un écosystème
petit naturel donc une forêt ou semi
naturels on va dire une prairie dans
lesquelles vous avez 250 à 300 tonnes de
carbone à l'hectare par une culture dans
laquelle vous avez de 80 à 150 tonnes de
carbone à l'hectare
il est évident que le delta entre les
deux pas sous forme de co2 dans
l'atmosphère et c'est le temps que vous
devez déduire si vous avez utilisé cette
nouvelle surface agricole pour faire des
biocarburants et c'est ce qui fait dire
à certains que par exemple le rendement
net des biocarburants en matière
d'économie de gaz à effet de serre quand
vous commencez par planter des palmiers
à huile en indonésie en veillant couper
la forêt primaire est un truc absolument
catastrophique moi j'ai jamais fait les
calculs parce que accéder à des données
fiables encore une fois est loin d'être
idéale mais le raisonnement l'ensemble
on peut très facilement comprendre
maintenant on va parler d'autre chose
qui s'appelle la géothermie la
géothermie c'est à l'échelle planétaire
le chauffage par le sol
c'est à dire
profiter de la chaleur qui est contenu
dans le gros test
alors vous allez de manière de prendre
sept comme vous le disais tout à l'heure
cette chaleur la première chose c'est
que vous pouvez regarder l'énergie qui
est libérée dans l'année par les
désintégrations radioactives qui ont eu
lieu dans l'année dans le globe
terrestre et ça vous vous rendez compte
que ça fait deux fois la consommation
d'énergie de l'humanité
répartie sur la totalité de la surface
de la planète donc le flux géothermique
annuel est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement faible
extrêmement faible ce qui est très
important c'est la chaleur accumulée
dans les entrailles de la terre
c'est à dire le stockage de chaleur que
vous avez dans les couches plus ou moins
profondes de la terre hélas un calcul
d'ordre de grandeur vous montre que vous
pouvez refroidir les entrailles de la
terre 20 degrés ce qui va pas
fondamentalement changé la face du monde
et vous avez accès à des centaines de
milliers de fois la consommation
d'énergie annuelle de l'humanité donc en
théorie vous pouvez vous dire que vous
avez là affaire à un potentiel
extrêmement important et la géothermie
vous pouvez en faire deux choses qui est
soit de la chaleur soit de l'électricité
la chaleur c'est pour le chauffage des
habitations
donc là vous faites de la de la
géothermie basse température
quand je dis basse température c'est pas
les pompes à chaleur dont je parlais
tout à l'heure c'est quand même aller
chercher un peu plus loin à quelques
dizaines de degrés et à paris vous avez
par exemple un bâtiment extrêmement
important qui est la maison de la radio
qui est chauffée avec de la géothermie
c'est à dire de la chaleur qu'on est
allé chercher à quelques centaines ou
vous ça doit être à quelques centaines
de mètres sous le sol à quelques
dizaines de degrés soixante dix où 86 la
géothermie haute température
il faut aller beaucoup plus profond que
ça où vous allez chercher de l'eau à
quelques centaines de degrés ou quelques
mois vous allez chercher des
températures de quelques centaines de
bugs c'est particulièrement facile
d'accéder à des roches
fait de manière importante quand vous
n'êtes pas loin d'une zone sismique ou
pas loin d'une zone volcanique ce qui
est souvent la même chose et vous avez
ici sur cette carte en autres les zones
où c'est particulièrement intéressant
d'exploiter la géothermie est ce que
vous êtes typiquement sur les femmes
vous êtes sur les failles de la croûte
la lnah chaleur remonte plus près de la
surface qu'ailleurs
quand vous faites de l'électricité en
allant chercher donc de la chaleur loin
voilà à quoi ressemble une installation
voilà à quoi ressemble le schéma
principe d'une installation qui permet
de faire ce genre de choses vous avez un
puits d'injection dans lequel vous
injecter de l'eau froide
vous allez faire circuler cette dans le
sous sol parce que la pression à
laquelle vous l'avez injecté lui permet
de circuler et vous allez remonter ici
longue et les puits de pompage ou
remonter le lac y ayant séjourné un
certain temps dans le sol s'est
réchauffée de manière très significative
en fait semaine de la vapeur et vous
allez utiliser la différence jeu moins
froid en surface pour fallu monter une
machine thermique et produire de
l'électricité alors dit comme ça ça a
l'air vachement simple en fait vous avez
un point extrêmement difficile à
franchir
dans ce genre de dispositif qui est que
quand votre eux aussi recul en
profondeur ici elle circule dans le
milieu naturel
elle n'est pas en milieu confiné elle
est pas dans une canalisation d'eau
qu'elles se chargent de tout ce qui
traîne dans le coin et tout ce qu'ils
traînent dans le coin en pratique ça
vous bouffent les canalisations
parce que vous allez récupérer des tas
de composés chimiques qui vont acidifier
plus ou moins fortement le hong qui vont
kobe ou attaquer les parties de votre
installation génératrice d'électricité
donc l'un d'eux problème très important
contre lesquels il faut lutter pour
faire ce genre d'installation est bien
évident que si vous commencez à gainer
rotule du platine
ça coûte un peu plus cher c'est la
corrosion parce que vous avez de l'eau à
haute température et à l'autre pression
chargé d'éléments corrosif qui se
battent dans le système donc c'est pas
simple à gérer
il ne reste pas moins que comme je
voulais montrer sur le graphique tout à
l'heure la géothermie
la troisième source d'énergie d'origine
renouvelable dans le monde
après l'hydroélectricité et vous avez
certains pays où ça représente la quasi
totalité de pendant une fraction très
significative de leur approvisionnement
énergétique et vous en avez noté morin
qui a présenté sur la carte ici qu'est
l'islande
l'islande est un pays où la géothermie
est quelque chose de très important
l'islande est quelque chose de la
géothermie est très important et c'est
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
l'islande a fait des grandes annonces en
disant qu'ils allaient passer à la
civilisation hydrogène l hilarant quand
vous avez la population boulogne
billancourt assis sur un volcan c'est
plus facile avec quelques milliards
d'individus ce sera plus dur parce que
la population de l'islande ces deux cent
mille personnes ont rejoint boulogne
billancourt ses 150 milles donc vous
avez la géothermie peut localement
représenter quelque chose de très
significatif
ou quand vous êtes assis sur les volcans
en gros c'est lamentable philippines à
ce moment ça peut être significatif
ailleurs c'est plus difficile parce
qu'il ya un certain nombre de
difficultés techniques à franchir après
vous pouvez vous servir du vent alors le
vent est quelque chose dont on parle
beaucoup en ce moment
le var est tout simplement lié à la
différence de température parce que
différence d'insolation ou différents
ensoleillement plus exactement que vous
avez sur le globe terrestre l'énergie
solaire son incidence est la plus
propice à réchauffer la surface quand
elle arrive aux tropiques et donc vous
avez un mouvement de circulation à
grande échelle qui prend place parce que
les tropiques ses cheveux et l'épaule
c'est froid si la terre ne tournait pas
sur elle-même
ben vous auriez justin mouvements
convectifs dans lequel lait remonte ici
et puis redescend là parce que vous avez
le maximum de l'insolation ici est le
minimum là donc le maximum de la chaleur
l'un le minimum là vous avez une boucle
de convection comme ça comme la prière
prononcera demain avec coriolis vient
s'en mêler
en fait c'est pas comme ça que les
choses se passent vous avez
effectivement une grande boucle de
convection comme ça mais elle
limité à ce qui se passe entre
l'équateur et des tropiques c'est ce
qu'on appelle les cellules de hadley je
vous en ai pas parlé pendant la partie
changement climatique mais si vous avez
affaire à des dynamicien d'atmosphère et
connaissent très bien ça ça s'appelle
les cellules de la dre et c'est ce qui
vous expliquent la pluviométrie très
important à l'équateur parce que quand
tu nous as est l'objet d'une ascendance
forte et bien toute la vapeur 2 se
condense à cause de la perte de
température et il pleut beaucoup et par
contre vous avez au dessus d'autres en
pick ce qu'on appelle des drones de
subsidence c'est à dire que vous avez de
l'air sec qui alors c'est pas aussi
simple que ça met en mouvement résultant
qui de sang et il pleut qui descend de
latitude et il pleut très peu et c'est
ce qui vous explique que quand vous
regardez la terre vous avez beaucoup de
végétation et beaucoup de pluie à
l'équateur et vous avez beaucoup de
désert et très peu de pluie aux
tropiques
c'est le résultat de cette convection à
grande échelle que vous avez ici et au
niveau des moyennes et les classes
issues d'un le système s'organise de
manière différente vous mettez à avoir
un système de dépressions et
anticyclones que vous connaissez bien
c'est à dire que les zones où l'air
montent ou descendent créé en fait des
petits vertex à cause de coriolis et ça
se met à s'enrouler alors tout ça ça
nous donne quand même des régimes de
vent et en particulier aux tropiques
vous avez des ventes sont relativement
régulier une partie de l'année qui
s'appelle les alizés et que vous pouvez
exploiter pour avoir de l'énergie
éolienne à bec
d'une certaine manière un
approvisionnement qui au moins une
partie de l'année peut être pas trop
intermittent ici ou du moins avec des
sautes qui sont pas trop violente
quand vous êtes dans un régime
d'oppression et d'anticyclone là c'est
plus exactement la même chanson ça peut
varier de manière significative
à l'échelle de la journée voire même de
leur camp vous êtes sur les continents
donc la convection à grande échelle
vous créez une circulation sur terre des
grandes masses d'air et puis après vous
avez évidemment des taxes et des
rebelles locaux qui viennent se rajouter
là-dessus là vous en avez un que vous
connaissez très bien si certains d'entre
vous font de la voile c'est les
thermiques que vous avez en bord de mer
où la différence de température que vous
avez entre la terre et l'océan qui varie
autour de la de la journée de 24 heures
un pardon vous créer des mouvements
ascendants qui prennent place au dessus
de la terre en journée et au dessus de
la mer pendant la nuit
parce que l'amplitude de thermique de la
terre est beaucoup plus importante que
l'amplitude thermique de bon ben ça
c'est typiquement quelque chose qui vous
crée également du vent et puis vous avez
pas le processus qui vous modifie le
vent à petite échelle donc le vent vous
en avez toujours un peu partout et d'une
manière générale l'énergie total
transporté par les vents vous voyez que
c'est toujours pareil quand vous
regardez pour la planète entière 25 à 30
fois la consommation d'énergie de
l'humanité ou dit waouh gisement énorme
je vous rappelle encore une fois qu'il
ya une énorme partie qui se baladent au
dessus de l'océan ou sepa extrêmement
facile de la récupérer et par ailleurs
quand vous regardez à une échelle
microscopique survaleurs et bien vous
vous rendez compte que l'énergie
cinétique contenu dans un mètre cube
d'air qui se déplace à 60
kilomètres/heure ça fait pas grand chose
quoi et vous pouvez bien d'en récupérer
50% ça aurait 50% de pas grand chose
tout simplement parce qu'un mètre cube
d'air ça pèse 2 kg voilà c'est pas très
dense que 60 kilomètres heure c'est pas
très rapides et donc vous avez des
quantités d'énergie mise en jeu qui à
l'échelle d'une machine qui captent sont
pas nécessairement très élevé générale
en france vous avez comme à la surface
de la planète des régimes de vent qui
sont variables suivant la localisation
et vous avez ici
la puissance moyenne annuelle en watts
par mètre carré de section verticale
pris un peu au dessus du sol pour
s'affranchir des turbulences en fonction
de l'endroit où vous situez donc vous
voyez que vous pouvez à ça peut varier
d'un facteur 5 en fonction de l'endroit
où vous situez ici vous êtes dans les
régimes de mistral
le vent devant lucio de l'équivalent
perpignan je me rappelle de son nom et
en relais vous êtes sur les régimes de
vent à temps sur les dépressions devant
atlantique et vous voyez que par exemple
la beauce qui est dans la zone verte ce
qui est une des zones les moins
favorables
c'est pourtant là que l'on va mettre le
plus grand parc éolien en service en
france dans pas très longtemps donc vous
avez les régimes de vent qui sont très
variables et ses régimes de vents très
variables vont évidemment conditionné de
manière très forte la rentabilité
économique parce que c'est toujours la
même et au yen qu'il faut construire
elles coûtent toujours le même prix il
faut toujours dépenser la même quantité
d'argent pour la maintenir
il faut toujours grosso modo dépenses et
la même quantité d'argent pour la
raccorder au réseau etc et le prix du
kilowattheure éolien est essentiellement
en fonction de la quantité de vent que
vous allez avoir là vous mettez votre
éolienne qualifiant seulement fonction
de ça plus le tarif de rachat est élevé
plus ça incite les gens à mettre des
éoliennes dans des embrouilles après le
coup en belgique
le principal 30 de l'éolien le voici
c'est le fait que vous avez de
l'électricité qui est produite d'une
manière qui peut varier assez fortement
à l'échelle de la journée et vous voyez
quand je dis qu'elle peut varier assez
fortement là vous avez aller a dit avant
je pense que les auteurs du rapport ont
choisi à dessein pour montrer ce qu'il
peut se passer quand tu le sais plus
perturbés mais ça vous donne quand même
une idée et c'est important de savoir
parce que quand vous gérer un réseau
vous avez besoin d'assurer l'équilibré
du réseau toute l'année 24 heures sur 24
et 60 minutes par heure
parce que si à un moment vous assurez
plus l'équilibré au réseau à votre
réseau s'effondre et en général ça
produit des conséquences désagréables
pour tout le monde
vous avez ici la variation sur
c'est des jouets mais ici au delà de la
quantité d'électricité produite par
alors ça s'appelle une ferme je peux
pour qu'on appelle ça une ferme
j'appellerai bien une zone industrielle
une ferme une usine ferme éolienne à
parc éolien qui est quelque part en
grande bretagne c'est à dire sur la
façade atlantique à un endroit où quand
même le vent donc le problème de
l'éolien le premier est le premier
problème de l'éolien c'est son
intermittence et c'est une intermittence
qui est difficilement prévisible et qui
est par ailleurs total c'est à dire que
l'éolienne ne se t'elle pas sur la
courbe de charge du réseau électrique en
décidant de produits arts compte la cour
augmente et de produits là quand lacombe
baisse parce que si elles étaient
intermittentes mais qu'elle est sur la
table de charge du réseau électrique
ça serait pas grave je serais même pas
fait ça voudrait dire que l'éolienne a
décidé tout seul de produire de
l'électricité de pointe
en fait c'est pas ça qui se passe ce qui
se passe c'est que si je reprends la
courbe de charge du réseau électrique
avec la contribution des divers moyens
et bien lu rien me rajoute un truc qui
est qui ressemble à ça alors
selon le parc selon où il est situé
selon ce qu'on appelle le foisonnement
c'est à dire le fait que vous ayez mis
des éoliennes dans des régimes de vent
différents et ils sont jamais tous
exactement nul au même moment et c'est
le talon auquel ça descend ici est
strictement nul ou bien ça peut être un
peu au dessus c'est à dire qu'à
n'importe quel moment dans la d vous
êtes à peu près sûrs d'avoir un
pourcentage de votre puissance installée
à l'échelle mondiale vous êtes à peu
près sûrs d'avoir un pourcentage de
votre puissance installée n'importe
quand à n'importe quel moment
à l'échelle d'un pays ces marais en
france vous pouvez avoir un jour dans
l'année un anticyclone dans lequel vous
avez devant nulle part on peut arriver à
l'échelle de l'europe c'est déjà un peu
moins vrai donc selon là encore une fois
les frontières du système sont
absolument essentielles pour savoir
comment est-ce que
enfin quel niveau se situe ce minimum il
n'en reste pas moins que vous allez
avoir comme ça une variation de la
production
et comme cette production elle arrive
sans vous demander votre avis on dit
qu'elle est fatale l'électricité fatale
dans un réseau électrique c'est
l'électricité qui arrive qu'au système a
décidé de produire et pas quand vous
vous en avez besoin
quand vous en avez besoin on appelle ça
un système commandable cédant c'est un
système c'est fatal ça veut dire que si
vous avez une graisse puissance éolienne
installée et bien dans les paquets de la
consommation de base c'est-à-dire en
greuze qui ici et le jaune espèces ou
john a et bien vous allez créer un
besoin de production de pointe
vous allez créer là vous arriviez à
satisfaire à vos besoins avec quelque
chose qui varie peu con du temps vous
allez devoir super peser à votre
production éolienne qui varient
significativement au compte du temps un
moyen très notable commandable qui lui
aussi va vous livrer une puissance qui
va varier rapidement au cours du temps
et ça vous n'avez que deux moyens
d'obtenir ce genre de choses c'est
l'hydroélectricité et les centrales
thermiques à flamme ce qui est une
manière de dire que dans un pays dans
lequel vous avez beaucoup
d'hydroélectricité si vous rajoutez
désir lienz est quelque chose qui peut
se gérer
vous pourriez rajouté en quantités
significatives ça peut se gérer sans
trop de problème on va dire si vous
voulez rajouter dans un pays qui n'a pas
d'hydroélectricité ou bien vous êtes
obligés de faire fonctionner de manière
différente
les centrales à charbon et à gaz et
l'entraînement vous êtes obligés d'en
rajouter
ou bien vous êtes obligé de faire appel
aux barrages du présent alors le
danemark par exemple est obligé se
rappelle aux barrages du grésas le
danemark a tellement d'éoliennes
aujourd'hui que si on fermait les
frontières électrique du danemark le
réseau serait porté en permanence dans
chaque camp ce qui est une manière de
dire que quand vous avez une source
d'électricité très intermittente
installé quelque part vous ne pouvez pas
ramener la production annuelle de cette
source la consommation de la zone
géographique qui concerne la source
aujourd'hui ramener la production
éolienne
noise à la consommation annuelle danoise
est un truc qui n'a aucun sens puisque
si le des noirs étaient seulement tu
pourrais pas avoir autant d'éoliennes
donc ça n'a aucun sens de ramener la
production éolienne danoise à la
consommation d'électricité danoise parce
que je suis claire ou est-ce que c'est
compliqué à comprendre les frontières du
système c'est pas les frontières
géographiques du danemark
c'est ça qui est en train de vous dire
ça va plus loin que ça et en fait ça
réglait des barrages scandinaves et
éventuellement les centrales à charbon
allemandes même pour les éoliennes
allemandes les bonnes frontières du
système ce n'est déjà plus l'allemagne
ça englobe les barrages français et
suisses s'ils n'avaient pas les barrages
français et suisses les allemands
pourraient pas avoir autant d owlient
que ce qu'ils ont aujourd'hui ça paye
bien évidemment cette question ça nous
ramène à une question que j'avais évoqué
à propos des biocarburants mais qu'on va
pouvoir est évoqué ici c'est à dire
tenez le couple intermittence et qui la
supporte
il est évident que si pour augmenter
leurs capacités éoliennes les allemands
oblige les suisses a rajouté des
barrages il ya un coût de
l'intermittence qui n'est pas
directement supportés par la personne
qui rajoute des éoliennes en allemagne
alors ce coup on peut être positif ou
négatif ça dépend à quel tarif les
suisses vont vendre l'électricité en
question mais il faut bien comprendre
encore une fois que la profusion que
vous pouvez tirer sur l'opportunité de
faire nous pas faire et après je vais
peut-être pas si c'est la prochaine fois
là dessus va toujours fondamentalement
départ des frontières du système de
l'ale vous considérez que vous devez
borne est ce que vous êtes en train de
regarder et que d'assez seulement
derrière que vous n'avez que que ce que
vous êtes en train de faire n'a pas des
faits observables de cassina là dessus
si vous rajoutez une intermittence
là vous aviez envoyé une production qui
était très stable et bien vous allez
avoir besoin de moyens de production de
pointe à plus et il se trouve que dans
la production électrique c'est la pointe
qui coûte cher bon la pertinence
économique de l'éolien est un truc qui
va dépendre de la quantité d'éoliennes
que vous installez c'est pas un truc qui
est pertinent sans seuil dans est un
tout petit peu quelques pourcents c'est
un truc qui ne pose pas de problème où
peut bien être intéressant vous ne
pourrez jamais avoir 20% d'électricité
d'origine
dans un système électrique c'est pas
possible parce que vous n'avez pas 20%
d'électricité de pointe disponible en
france il ya 1 15% ya un petit 15%
aujourd'hui on est à 13 on est à 13 et
on a déjà besoin de cette
hydroélectricité pour réguler ce qui
existe déjà
donc si vous voulez rajouter de la
pointe pour réguler des trucs qui
n'existe pas encore et bien vous n'avez
pas les barrages nécessaire pour ça ce
qui veut dire que vous allez créer des
centrales à gaz et les centrales à
charbon pour ça ce qui est très
exactement ce que les opérateurs de
centrales et 2e à gaz et à charbon
attendait quand vous discutez avec eux
ils vous disent l'éolien c'est une
excellente affaire pour vous encore un
domaine dans lequel la vérité n'est pas
nécessairement dans le journal alors je
vais vous donner quelques ordres de
grandeur pour vous permettre d'avancer
un tout petit peu
ou de conclure mais enfin d'avancer un
petit peu sur ce débat en allemagne
ils ont aujourd'hui installé à peu près
20 gigawatts de puissance éolienne
alors il faut savoir qu'une éolienne
unitairement ces quelques mégawatts de
puissance
n'importe quoi entre un et six ou sept
j'allais dire mais voilà retenez que ces
quelques mégawatts
une centrale conventionnelle qu'il
s'agisse d'une tranche à charbon ou
d'une centrale nucléaire on est plutôt
dans les eaux de 1000 à 1500 mégawatts
électriques 1 donc il faut comparer ce
qui est comparable
là aussi fait attention à une chose
c'est que dans le journal on a souvent
un égal un temps qu'un vélo il ya une
centrale à charbon il ya une éolienne et
diallo l'un panneaux solaires il ya eu
une ampoule et atx pourquoi non il faut
il faut regarder les désordres du
vendeur
par ailleurs une tranche à charbon une
centrale nucléaire comme je voulais
montrer sur le diagramme précédent ça
tourne en permanence si je vous
reprocher de ce diagramme là vous voyez
que la centrale nucléaire elle tourne en
permanence et mon hydroélectricité au
fil de le tourner en permanence ça veut
donc dire que sur les huit mille sept
cent soixante heures que j'ai dans
l'année le facteur de charge de l'est de
l'hydroélectricité au fil de l'eau belle
2760 moi un petit grain petits pas grand
chose pour la maintenance
le facteur de charge du nucléaire va
être compris entre sept et huit mille
exactement comme celui du chardon si je
fais mon électricité de base au charbon
là en ce qui concerne l'éolien je vais
plutôt me balader dans les 2000 joueur
utile dans l'année ce qui veut dire que
le productible annuel c'est pas la
puissance installée fois 8000 c'est la
puissance installée froides aux mille ha
ça peut être 1500 dans les cas de figure
est du reste en allemagne comme c'est
une grande plaine pas très ventée ils
sont plutôt en dessous de 2000 en
général ça peut être 3 miller utile dans
les bons cas de figure par exemple dans
le couloir rhodanien
dans certains endroits très particulier
du couloir rhodanien et de comparer
telle puissance installée
il faut comparer les énergies produites
en bout de course à la fin de l'année
par ailleurs si vous regardez ce que
représente la poire éoliens en allemagne
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est de l'ordre de
40 térawatts heure c'est à dire 6 % de
l'électricité qu'ils produisent leur
consommation d'électricité ayant
augmenté de 15 % sur les dix dernières
années donc vous voyez que si on fait du
'business as usual' avec la consommation
d'électricité qui évolue de son côté et
les éoliennes qu'on rajoute de l'autre
le bilan net de la faire c'est qu'on
n'est pas du tout dans les clous et que
en fait ils ont rajouté dans le même
temps notre à 10% d'électricité qui
n'est pas l'éolienne et chez eux
vous savez vous ce fort à la fois du
nucléaire et du chardon mais en
l'occurrence avec pour plus de la moitié
de l'électricité supplémentaire du
charbon donc par ailleurs fait attention
à une autre chose c'est que je voulais
déjà dit j'aime beaucoup que j'aime
beaucoup les journalistes je leur fais
beaucoup dessus vous avez un dans le
journal on vous parle beaucoup de
l'éolien parce que le journal réagi à
des acteurs qui se manifestent c'est
comme ça que ça marche
un journal sérieux c'est un centre de
tri c'est un endroit où tous les joueurs
vous recevez des communiqués de presse
des coups de fil des soucis de ceux là
donc si vous avez quelqu'un qui tous les
jours vous dis mon barrages illégaux
vous aurez en paradis l'eau et
l'électricité dans ce journal et si on
vous dit pas tout les jours mon barrage
il est bon on vous parlera pas
d'hydroélectricité dans le journal quand
on construit un barrage tous les jours
en france on vous parle pas
d'hydroélectricité comme ya toujours un
endroit où on est en train de construire
une éolienne
on vous parle de l'éolien il n'en reste
pas moins que la france a une part
d'électricité d'origine renouvelable
dans son mix est supérieure à celle du
danemark à cause de l'hydroélectricité
qui fait le double de ce que peu à peu
près le double de ce qu'il ya en
allemagne à cause de l'hydroélectricité
surtout comment connaît encore une fois
construit pas en barrages tous les jours
on n'en parle pas beaucoup dans le
journal on fait attention à ça là aussi
1 n'est pas égal à 1 un barrage s'est
pas loin d'être 500 à 1000 fois la
puissance installée d'une éolienne
on n'est pas en train de parler des
nageurs de vendeurs autres choses
intéressantes à regarder
je me suis amusé si l'on peut dire à
regarder l'électricité produite au
danemark
eh bien c'est ce que je vous disais tout
à l'heure si le danemark avait des
frontières électrique servez les danois
n'aurait pas d'électricité très souvent
leur production elle est passée de 46 à
36 donc elle a baissé de 25% en deux ans
avant de remonter de 36 à 40 6 en une
année là vous avez la conséquence d'un
hiver vanter ou d'un hiver peu venté que
vous pouvez avoir à partir du moment où
vous avez une très grande fraction du
parc installé qui est constitué de
moyens intermittents et bien vous avez
une production électrique qui peut prés
fortement fluctuer d'une année sur
l'autre et je peux vous assurer que si
vous allez voir les électriciens en leur
demandant si dans un système fermé
ils savent gérer la consommation à peu
près quasi identique un truc comme ça et
ils vont évidemment vous dire non ils
vont évidemment vous dire non donc ça
c'est la contrepartie de ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure
cette affaire ne marche que parce que
les éoliennes danois sont interconnectés
au garage scandinaves et aux centrales
allemandes
dernier point qu'il faut garder en
mémoire peur les dispositifs qui vous
produisent de la moyenne ou de la haute
tension et c'est le calme et au lien qui
vous produit la moyenne tension
la notion de consommation locale
n'existe pas
les barrages des alpes équilibre le
réseau à brest ça n'existe pas la
consommation locale pour une soit pour
un dispositif qui produit qui injecte
sur le réseau tht ça n'existe pas donc
l'idée de je vais avec une éolienne
produire les électrons qui sont à côté
de chez moi
elle est ni plus ni moins valides que
l'idée
qui consiste à dire parce que j'habite à
côté de la centrale nucléaire c'est
cette électricité là est celle qui
directement même alimenté mois non c'est
des dispositifs qui injecte de la
puissance dans un réseau les pertes en
lignes du réseau tht d'un bout à l'autre
de la france et 2 % donc n'importe quel
dispositif qui injecte de la puissance
n'importe où en france
équilibrer le réseau n'importe où
ailleurs en france il n'existe pas de
notion de production locale avec si vous
avez un panneau solaire qui vous
crachent du quelques valses que vous
avez stockée dans une batterie ça oui
c'est de la production locale c'est très
clair par contre pour les dispositifs de
puissance qui vous injecte l'électricité
dans le réseau tht il n'existe pas de
production de 4 elle n'existe pas alors
maintenant je vous parle est un tout
petit peu d'argent et vous allez
comprendre pourquoi ces énergies
d'origine renouvelable
outre les limitations physiques dans
jeanne vous parlez encore une fois parce
que vous avez un certain nombre de
limitations physiques et bien elles vont
quand même avoir du mal à être
compétitive même avec un pétrole qui va
significativement augmenté quand je
baille de pétrole sort depuis je vous en
avais parlé la dernière fois le coût
d'extraction de ce bail de pétrole va se
balader aux alentours de 10 dollars
actuellement à 1,25 dollar par le savent
mais le kilowattheure de pétrole à 0 4
centime 24 sorties du dispositif de
production c'est-à-dire le puits en aide
si vous allez en sortie de raffineries
vous êtes toujours à mon avis ou deux
centimes le kilowattheure vous prenez du
gaz sur le marché de gros est donc là il
est même pas en sortie depuis il est
sorti transporté disponible vous êtes
aux alentours de 2 centimes
vous prenez un qu'il aurait peur
nucléaire ou un kilowattheure charbon
sans tenir compte du co2 vous êtes à 3 à
4 centimes
maintenant on va regarder pour les deux
grandes d'électricité d'origine
renouvelable dont la presse fait
largement écho
prenons par exemple éolien vous êtes à 8
centimes par kilowattheure en tarif de
rachat mais c'est sans tenir compte de
l'intermittent
ce qui est supporté par d'autres acteurs
économiques ailleurs et en fait si vous
faites un calcul on va dire date de
vendeurs par exemple vous stockez sur
place ou stockés au pied des éoliennes
avec un gros dispositif de stockage et
vous ne revendez l'électricité quand
sortie de dispositifs de stockage avec
un dispositif qui devient non plus
fatale mais comment diable vous doubler
100 et si vous faites un petit calcul
sur le fait que quand vous installer une
éolienne vous avez nécessairement besoin
ailleurs de quasiment la puissance
installée en réserve pour être capable
de pallier les périodes 120 grand'rue ça
veut dire que vous avez besoin de
doubler votre coût d'investissement
c'est ça que ça veut dire très
clairement et bien ce couple
intermittence qui pour le moment n'est
pas le tarif de rachat il est supporté
par d'autres personnes
d'ailleurs si vous le réintégrer là
dedans vous allez à mon avis montée très
nettement au dessus de 10 et plus tôt ou
blonde et aux alentours de 15
en ce qui concerne le photovoltaïque là
vous êtes aux alentours de 50 centimes
le kilowattheure acheter alors est ce
que ça veut dire que ça c'est scandaleux
j'en sais rien ça veut surtout dire que
vous allez retrouver ici dans le
différentiel de prix des raisons qui
sont fondamentalement des raisons
physiques que j'ai essayé vous exposez
jusqu'à maintenant et qui font que le
pétrole que la nature a fait tout seul
en quelques dizaines de millions
d'années encore une fois avec des
rendements delà de 10 - 2
et sans qu'on ait eu besoin de mettre la
main à la pâte vous propose un produit
qui est considérablement plus performant
que ce qu'on peut faire nous avec nos
petits bras musclés en temps réel à
partir du vent ou du soleil ou des
biocarburants etc
voilà c'est juste ça que ça signifie et
pour des raisons physiques le delta
entre ces deux trucs là va être
extrêmement sinon impossible difficile à
combler pour andrea monde dans lequel on
vit avec plus d'énergie renouvelable ce
qui va de toute façon être le cas quand
l'approvisionnement fossile va commencer
à baisser et ce qui devrait être le cas
le plus vite possible pour que
l'approvisionnement énergétique commence
à baisser
mais ça va se faire surtout avec des
économies et à peu avec un changement
d'offre est bien est un monde dans
lequel vous allez de toute façon payer
votre énergie plus chère
l'idée qu'on peut vivre comme
aujourd'hui avec des énergies
renouvelables disponibles en prix et un
volume un même appareil est
malheureusement une idée naïve c'est à
dire une idée qui ne correspond pas à la
réalité des faits est l'une des choses
que vous aurez peut-être à faire dans
vos métiers sera justement d'imaginer
comment est-ce que le monde se met à
fonctionner à partir du moment où le
prix de l'énergie non pas des croix de
manière structurelle à ce que je vous
avais expliqué là du premier cours mais
croît de manière structurelle est ce que
les sources disponibles ne permettent
pas de continuer d approvisionnement qui
en prix et en volume soit identique à ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui
dix ans
ça dépend aujourd'hui pour faire un
panneau photovoltaïque vous avez besoin
d'électricité
cette électricité l est pas produite par
du photovoltaïque elle est produite par
du charbon du gaz et du nucléaire
le kilowattheure au gaz et le
kilowattheure au charbon le coût de la
matière primaire c'est-à-dire le gaz et
le charbon c'est à peu près la moitié du
coût de votre kilowattheure donc dans un
monde dans lequel le prix de l'énergie
fossile décuple le prix du kilowattheure
photovoltaïque montrent tout se tient
tous tient à long terme surtout ce
moment c'est cette citation mais avant
on en arrive là
en fait vous vous rendez compte que les
ordres de grandeur sont elles je vais
venir à la fin de ce cours les ordres de
grandeur sont telles que d'imaginer que
ces trucs là qui représente 0 07 % de
l'énergie mondiale et 0,003 % de
l'énergie mondiale vont dans les 20 ans
qui viennent ont représenté 50% à virer
4 centimes le kilowattheure
on est bien d'accord oui dans mais même
ça ça à 20 % de l'approvisionnement
mondial
je serai en conviant dans 20 ans je
voulais prendre part et tout de suite je
veux également je veux parler des
l'énergie marémotrice alors l'énergie
marémotrice
elle consiste à exploiter
j'allais dire non pas le rayonnement
solaire donc là ce qui nous intéresse
c'est pas la bonne table au nucléaire
ici c'est juste la masse en fait vous
savez que les compartiments liquide de
la planète sont déformés par
l'attraction terrestre est l'attraction
lunaire est longue de marée qui se crée
peut être exploité en particulier dans
les zones du monde dans lesquels vous
avez ce qu'on appelle des mariages
important c'est à dire que l'une de
marée
ne tient pas de manière entrer en
résonance et vous allez avoir une
différence entre la marée haute et la
marée basse qui est très significative
alors deux autres bien connu une chez
nous ça tombe bien la baie du mont saint
michel
une autre chez les canadiens la baie
d'hudson et à ce moment vous pouvez
avoir une forme des cluses
c'est à dire que vous laissez nous
passer de la mer vers la rivière quand
la barre et monte et vous laisser le
passé de la rigueur vers la mer quand la
marée basse et dans les deux cas de
figure de turbines et au passage
d'accord bon ben ça ça vous donne ce
qu'on appelle une usine marémotrice vous
en avait une dans la rance dont la
puissance installée devant de 250
mégawatts et c'est quelque chose qui
fonctionne très bien
c'est ce que vous voyez que l'ombre de
bari à l'échelle planétaire
c'est une fraction de l'énergie
consommée par l'humanité donc on peut
faire un peu de marie moteur ici et là
mais on n'en fera pas des trucs qui sont
absolument faramineux dans les autres
énergies tirer de là mais avant je vous
ai pas parlé il ya les vagues
yala hull il ya ce qu'on appelle des
hydroliennes c'est à dire le fait de
profiter des courants de marée que vous
avez typiquement dans la branche à cause
de l'ombre de marée alors tout ça c'est
des choses qui peuvent fonctionner et en
particulier dans la manche les
hydroliennes on pourrait n'être que
gigawatts de puissance installée c'est
un truc qui est pas complètement
délirant et dans la plus si vous décalez
vos hydroliennes dakar de longueur
d'onde
vous avez une production d'électricité
de base en permanence donc ça peut être
un dispositif extrêmement intéressant
mais là comme ailleurs
vous allez avoir toujours une
concurrence d'usagé des sols ou de
l'espace c'est quelque chose dont je
vous ai pas parlé encore jusqu'à
maintenant mais en vo toutes les
énergies renouvelables vous avez besoin
d'occuper du sol ou d'occuper de
l'espace pour vous en servir
le solaire vous avez besoin d'occuper de
l'espace des biocarburants ou la
biomasse les besoins d'occuper de
l'espace l'hydraulique vous avez besoin
d'occuper de l'espace etc
donc les énergies renouvelables d'une
manière générale elles viendront
toujours en concurrence avec l'autre
utilisation de l'espace que vous
pourriez avoir envie de faire et
notamment une utilisation pour nourrir
qu'il s'agisse de la forêt qu'il
s'agisse des biocarburants qu'il
s'agisse d'un raid de barrage qui saisit
de
le lac de barrage peut venir en
concurrence avec la fonction alimentaire
pas tant sur l'occupation du sol que sur
la convention poissons etc
donc vous allez avoir vous allez avoir
d'une manière générale en ce qui
concerne les énergies renouvelables très
souvent une concurrence d'usagé une
concurrence du match de sol qui peut
être gênante ou qui peut ne pas l'être
mais qu'il ne faut pas oublier on va
revenir dans cette affaire maintenant
qu'on a passé en revue un certain nombre
d'énergies renouvelables et on aurait pu
en passer d'autres en revue parce que
vous avez quelques petits trucs
exotiques dont je vous ai pas parlé on
va me manquer aux décharges de travers
mathieu de charge
je vous rappelle que si on veut avoir la
vision conventionnelle de l'avenir c'est
à dire de plus en plus d'énergie avec de
moins en moins de co2 eh bien on est
face à l'obligation d'avoir des taux de
croissance qui sont de l'ordre de 4 à 5
% par an pour ceux qui n'est ni fossiles
ni émetteurs de co2 dans le même temps
qu'on fait baisser sa de l'invs indique
500 par an alors physiquement faire
baisser sa de l'amérique 5% par an c'est
très facile je sais très facilement
faire je fais monter les prix ça de
l'augmenter de 4 5% par an that is the
question
et on va repartir de notre des
compositions actuelles pour voir si les
intérêts composés permettent d'envisager
une ont ce genre de choses 7 % par an
vous savez tous faire avec 0,4 à la
puissance 50
ça veut dire que je dois multiplier bon
approvisionnement par sept en l'espace
de cinquante ans donc quand
l'approvisionnement renouvelables je
dois multiplié par sept par l'espace de
50 ans dans le même temps soit dit en
passant que je vis ici par cette
l'approvisionnement nucléaire en
l'espace de cinquante ans je fais les
deux en même temps est ce que je peux
faire x 7
en ce qui concerne la contribution de la
biomasse et bien
sans amènerait on brûle elle a utilisé
pas loin de 20 % des terres émergées à
des fins énergétiques
actuellement la forêt mondial c'est 25 %
des terres émergées
oui c'est bien sauf que si vous
transformez la forêt mondiale en
plantation d'eucalyptus ou un peu pleuré
j'ai pas sûr que vous allez encore très
envie d'aller vous balader dimanche
et plus sérieusement en ce qui concerne
la biodiversité c'est à dire hausse donc
vous avez un certain et si jamais vous
avez tous transformés en plantation
d'eucalyptus et puis caraïbes à cause du
changement climatique
le diable de l'eucalyptus ça te dire le
machin qui vous tue vos et qualiplus
avec ce genre de plan je suis pas sûr
que ce soit extrêmement réaliste et puis
c'est pas d'ingénieur des mines français
qui va décider ce que le brésilien va
faire de sa forêt ses brésiliens qui va
décider et l'indonésien qui va décider
donc sur le papier c'est comme pour
l'approvisionnement énergétique en
provenance du soleil sept mille fois et
ses terrasses en fête
je suis extrêmement perplexe quant au
fait que l'on puisse arriver à un tel
niveau et bien même temps il faudra
multiplier par cinq la contribution de
l'hydroélectricité quand les hydro
électricien quand vous leur posez la
question vous disent que ce qui est
techniquement faisable c'est de l'or
d'une multiplication par trois mêmes
cette multiplication par 3 suppose de
mettre les bouchées doubles sur un
certain nombre d'investissements qui
seront peut-être pas très éco freddy
après on commence à regarder d'autres
trucs qui deviennent plus marrant
aujourd'hui on consomme comme je vous le
disais 4000 millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole devrait pétrole 3800
pour être précis alors on se débarrasse
du pétrole d'abord parce qu'il y en aura
moins en moins et ensuite parce qu'il
fait du changement climatique et on le
remplace par des biocarburants et dans
le même temps on considère que la prep
raison que les ingénieurs des mines
parisien il est plus accès à des
voitures que n'importe quel asiatiques
africains ou américains du sud
donc je double à au moins foire je
triple le parc de voitures parce que
c'est comme ça que tu équitable ça veut
dire qu'il faudrait que je passe de 20
millions de tonnes équivalent pétrole à
7000 en ce qui concerne des
biocarburants en l'espace de 45 ans et
soit dit en passant si les rendements ne
s'améliore pas ça veut dire que ça je
dois trop
six mille fois trouvé cinq à six giga
tech ailleurs par exemple sous forme
d'électricité nucléaire ou de chaleur
duc les airs pour produire des
biocarburants puisque ça c'est de
l'énergie finale et pas de l'énergie
primaire
voilà est-ce que je vais réussir à faire
passer les 6,5 millions de tonnes
équivalent-pétrole d'éolien à quelque
chose de significatif à l'échelle avant
vous soyez mans et même avant que les
emmerdements démarre personnellement
j'en doute
et en ce qui concerne le photovoltaïque
c'est eux et je vais finir par
l'illustration du passé c'est
intéressant de revenir au passé de temps
en temps même si l'avenir n'est jamais
la répétition du passé vous avez ici
le taux de croissance annuel moyen sur
50 ans d'accord je prends la croissance
annuelle moyenne sur des plages de 50
ans donc c'est une moyenne glissante sur
les 50 ans qui ont précédé pour les
trois énergies qui domine aujourd'hui le
mix c'est à dire le pétrole le gaz et le
charbon
je prends par exemple la consommation de
pétrole telle qu'elle a été en moyenne
de 1860 1910 et je regarde qu'elle est
factuel a évolué pardon 1860 1910 et je
regarde quelle est l'augmentation
annuelle moyenne et je tombe sur 13 %
donc le pétrole à ses débuts produit
miracle extraordinaire et cetera un crû
de 13% par an en moyenne sur de 1860
1910 si je prends la moyenne annuelle
glissante de jeu prendre 1900 à 1950 et
bien le pétrole sur cette période là il
a su en moyenne de 6 5% de 1900 à 1950
c'est +6 25% par an en moyenne si je me
situais la veille des premiers chocs
pétroliers et bien sûr les 50 ans qui
ont précédé 1920 à 1970 il a cru en
plein boom des trente glorieuses 1 2 + 6
% par an en moyenne
en ce qui concerne le charbon il a cru
aussi
c'est une énergie plus ancienne et vous
voyez que en gros ça pas dépasser les 4%
de croissance annuelle moyenne sur une
plage de 50 ans sur le siècle et demi
qui vient de s'écouler et le gaz est
quelque chose qui n'a pas dépassé les 8%
de croissance annuelle moyenne sur 50
ans aujourd'hui vous allez des
croissances annuelles en moyenne mais
des croissances annuelles sur le
photovoltaïque ou l'éolien qui
commettent de 30 à 50% mais vous avez vu
de quel niveau on part évidemment si on
faisait plus 50% sur ces trucs là pour
bon 50 ans ça commencerait à venir
significative dans 50 ans ce que
l'histoire
pour le moment je dis bien pour le
moment nous mais notre que les taux de
croissance annuels moyens qu'on peut
espérer avoir sur des technologies qui
commence à devenir mature ne sont plus
de 50 % par an
regardez aujourd'hui les taux de
croissance dans le domaine des télécoms
ou de l'internet alors qu'au début on
avait des taux de croissance annuel
moyen qui était à deux chiffres et à
deux gros chiffres
aujourd'hui vous êtes pas à 50% par an
et pourtant et décroissance qui sont
fortes mais vous êtes plutôt aux
alentours de 10 plus ou moins quelque
chose hein
eh bien je sais c'est ça qui me fait
dire que la structure de société est
ainsi fait que les innovations
intéressantes au début elle évolue est
le monde très vite et il ya notamment
les subventions qui peuvent porter sur
ce genre de choses tant que c'est des
petits volumes tant que ont produit en
france un pouillème de notre électricité
avec du photovoltaïque
on peut racheter le kilowattheure à 50
centimes le joueur en pleine récession
parce que le pic de production du
pétrole va problèmes en nous en amener
une on devrait financer la moitié
d'électricité française à 50 centimes du
kilowattheure qui comptaient même pas
capable argent dans les caisses de
l'état pour ça je pourrais vous donner
sans devoir vous amuser à calculer
l'ordre de grandeur de ce que ça
représente
c'est de l'argent qui n'existe pas donc
il faut faire très attention il faut
faire très attention vous ne vous ne
pouvez pas quand vous regardez les
potentiels de ces trucs là encore une
fois leur extraction et d'une manière
générale quand vous avez besoin de gérer
le changement vous ne pouvez pas faire
abstraction d'un retour vers le passé
regardez ce que dans des situations dans
lesquelles les gens avaient vraiment
besoin de bouger très vite on a été ou
les situations dans lesquelles de fait
ça à bouger très vite parce que
l'expansion des de l'industrialisation a
été très rapide
1 à quelle vitesse elle s'est développée
et ça vous donne pas une bande
supérieure à franchissable mais ça vous
donne quand même une idée de l'inertie
des sociétés humaines et du fait que
encore une fois des taux de croissance à
50% qui vont perdurer sur 50 ans je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait un seul domaine
dans lequel on est observée ce genre de
choses voilà donc je le finis à mes
panorama des énergies renouvelables là
dessus en revenant à ce petit graphique
qui est que compte tenu de leur niveau
de départ
compte tenu des échéances encore une
fois je vous renvoie au cours précédent
en ce qui concerne le pétrole on parle
de la décennie qui vient
en ce qui concerne la nécessité de faire
baisser les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre on parle de la décennie qui vient
en ce qui concerne le maximum
productible toutes énergies confondues
même si on veut pas qu'on parle de votre
génération
il est extrêmement peu probable pour moi
que les énergies renouvelables qui sont
là jouent un rôle majeur dans
l'approvisionnement énergétique avant
que vos enfants et votre âge sinon bien
c'est extrêmement peu probable
ça veut dire que l'essentiel de votre
vie professionnelle vous allez devoir
évoluer dans un monde qui va devenir
progressivement de plus en plus
rock'n'roll avec ce genre de choses qui
ne changeront pas significativement le
cours des événements ça veut pas dire
que ceux d'entre vous qui ont travaillé
chez les gens qui produisent ce genre de
choses auront une mauvaise affaire
il ya des tas d'applications niche pour
lesquelles ça peut être très intéressant
et je vais vous prendre un exemple c'est
les biocarburants les biocarburants
ce que la france peut raisonnablement
produire des biocarburants sens quand on
crève de faim c'est quelque chose qui
permettrait largement de faire avancer
les tracteurs ça c'est typiquement ce
que j'appelle une application niche
faire avancer les tracteurs c'est quand
même pas complètement sans intérêt sauf
à ce que vous ayez envie de changer de
métier et d'aller faire pousser des
patates mais sinon c'est quand même pas
complètement son intérêt mais si vous
faites avant ses détracteurs
n'omettez pas une goutte de carburant
dans une voiture par une goutte vous
pouvez éventuellement avec le biogaz
faire avancer les bus ça c'est un acte
de grandeur aussi qui est cohérent mais
vous n'en aurez pas une goutte
supplémentaire pour faire tourner
l'industrie ou ce que vous voulez et les
fora vert donc il ya des tas
d'applications niche dans lesquels on
peut être prêt à payer l'énergie très
cher parce que la valeur ajoutée à mener
est extrêmement forte et en particulier
par exemple dans l'agriculteur pan
quatre acteurs substitue une personne
employée pour aller vider la terre vous
pouvez payer le litre d'huile ou le
livre de bio diesel cher avant que ça
cesse de valoir le coup autant pour la
consommation de masse pour l'ensemble de
l'humanité
ces trucs là ne font quasiment pas de
différence dans les 20 à 30 ans qui
viennent voilà donc fin de cette édition
sur le renouvelable
la prochaine fois je vous parlerai donc
du bilan carbone c'est-à-dire delà de la
dune nous interspect yves tout ce que
j'ai évoquées jusqu'à maintenant et puis
je vous fais un quart d'heure sur les
voies professionnelles ou du moins ce
que j'en sais